نبدا من التهديدات المتبادله بين اسرائيل
وحزب الله فبعد تحذير رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي من تداعيات اي معركه على
الجبهه الشماليه
وجاهزيه الجيش للقتال قال نائب الامين
العام لحزب الله اللبناني نعيم قاسم ان
الحزب يدعم فكره وحده الساحات في مواجهه
اسرائيل ويمتلك قدرات استثنائيه لخوض اي
معركه تفرض عليه مع اسرائيل واضاف قاسم في
حديث صحفيا المناوره التي اجريت يوم الاحد
الماضي بعثت برسائل عن جاهزيه الحزب مشيرا
الى ان ما تم عرضه خلال هذه المناوره هو
جزء مما لديه ولا فتقاسم الى ان صواريخ
الدقيقه لم تعرض خلال هذه المناوره
اكد قائد الجيش اللبناني جوزيف استمرار
قيام الجيش بواجباته خاصه على الحدود
الجنوبيه بالتنسيق مع قوه الامم المتحده
المؤقته في لبنان يونيفال وفق القرار
الدولي رقم
1701 وشدد في مناسبه مناسبه ذكرى الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من جنوب لبنان عام 2000 شدد في
بيان على حق بلاده في مقاومه اسرائيل
واطماعها وخروقاتها للسياده واسترجاع كامل
الاراضي اللبنانيه المحتله اكد قائد الجيش
اللبناني على اولويه حفظ امن لبنان
واستقراره والدفاع عنه وضبط حدوثه
انا من بيروت مدير مكتبه الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم مازن اذا اضيف الى موقف حزب الله
اليوم موقف لقائد الجيش اللبناني لكن ما
هي خلفيه هذا التصعيد في الخطاب الذي
شهدناه في الاونه الاخيره وتوج بتلك
المناوره التي قام بها حزب الله في جنوب
لبنان
في الواقع حسن تمت ديناميه متغيره جديده
يعتمدها حزب الله منذ اشهر في محاوله منه
للقيام بامرين الاول هو تثبيت معادله
الردع التي كانت قد ارسلت خلال السنوات
الماضيه والمعادله الثانيه ترتبط بتثبيت
قواعد الاشتباك من جهه وتطويرها بمعنى ان
قواعد الاشتباك التي كانت قد تم تثبيتها
بعد حرب عام 2006 اليوم حزب الله من خلال
كل الديناميه التي يتحرك من خلالها عبر
المرحله الماضيه وصولا الى المناوره
العسكريه التي اجراها والتصريحات المتعدده
لكافه قادته من الامين العام للحزب مرورا
برئيس المجلس التنفيذي هاشم صفيه الدين
الذي يتحدث في نفس النهار الذي تم تنفيذ
المناوره العسكريه في جنوب لبنان وبالامس
نائب الامين العام الجميع باتا يتحدث عن
تثبيت قواعد الاشتباك ولكن هذه القواعد لم
تعد شكرا على جنوب لبنان بمعنى ان قاعده
الاشباك الاساسيه مع اسرائيل بدات تشمل
ساحات متعدده من هنا يمكن فهم هذا التشديد
الذي بدنا نلمسه خلال الايام والاسابيع
الماضيه من خلال تصريحات مسؤوليه حزب الله
ما يتعلق بوحده الساحات وعندما يجري
الحديث هنا عن وحده الساحات هي تشمل
بطبيعه الحال الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
من جهه جنوب لبنان وايضا تم تطوير هذا
الامر مرورا بالاراضي السوريه لاسيما بعد
الاستهدافات المتعدده من قبل الطيران
الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف مسؤولين وكوادر في
مستشارين في الحرس الثوري الايراني وايضا
حزب الله خلال الفتره الماضيه ولكن الجديد
الان هو ان تشمل معادله الرضع هذه ايضا
ايران وطهران بمعنى ان الكلام السابق
لامين العام لحزب الله كان واضحا بان اي
استهداف اسرائيلي لطهران ولبرنامجها
النووي سيؤدي الى فتح مواجهه تشمل المنطقه
كلها وبال من هنا يمكن ان نفهم الديناميه
المتغيره لحزب الله والتي تم تتويجها بهذه
المناوره العسكريه والتي كان هنالك ردود
فعل واضحه من الجانب الاسرائيلي وقلق وهو
ما استدعى تاكيدا من خلال الايام الماضيه
خلال الايام الماضيه من خلال
التصريحات التي ادلى بها مسؤولوها حزب
الله بان هنالك متغيرا فعليا في كيفيه
مقاربه كل هذه المعادله بطبيعه الحال
عندما يجري الحديث من قبل حزب الله عن هذه
الاطر لمواجهه المستقبليه وفتح كل الساحات
على بعضها البعض هذا الامر يدخل بعض
الخشيه على مستوى الداخلي اللبناني وهو ما
عبر عنه بشكل يقرا بين سطوره رئيس الحكومه
عندما التقى منسقه الامم المتحده في لبنان
وقال بان بيروت لا تريد ان يكون هنالك اي
متغير على مستوى كيفيه مقاربه الواقع في
جنوب لبنان وهو مندرج ايضا ضمنه الكلام
الذي الصادر اليوم عن قائد الجيش اللبناني
الذي قال بان الجيش سيعمل مع قوات الامميه
في جنوب لبنان وفق القرار 1901 شكرا لك
مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره احدثتنا
من بيروت